こんにちは
はずし使って僕はこの部屋でブランコを作ろうと頑張ったバンカーリングでその結果が
こちらだっ3
どぅんあの墓石に失敗たんですけどもう今回はするリベンジというかもっとちょっと
できそうなんだったんですねもう一度室内でブランコ
すると思いますこちらマジック
いうものでございますあのよくあるフックなんですけどもうこれからのアマゾンで見
たらすごい強いみたいなことを蔵庫で入れました
これですこれ
じゃあもう
これすごいっすよもう画像は全てを物語ってるんですけども
人はブラ差が出るみたいですやすぐで男の人が無効どうしてもなかっといけないみたい
なまず主語したというか実際何キロぐらいまで耐えれるんだろうえっと豪鬼楼から10
キロまで耐えれるみたいです
ちょっとたリンガー一個大隊10キロ使えば40キロいや大丈夫ですよ
ちょっと不安になってきたないやでを見て下さいこの女性が服一つで浮いてるんでひと
つで女性が含んできっと僕も大丈夫だと思いますと呼びを作っていきましょうまずは
ブランコを作りますブランコのリーダーとしてこれを使います
このサイズのでかいなフラ5票で go
キーということで体の大衆の分散するので読みフック一つの端にかかる授業がちょっと
軽くなるって言う均等になるんじゃないかなと思ってこれを採用しますまず穴を開け
ます
よし idee プレッシャーも毛穴が出来ましたここにひもを通していきます
を検査車
よしこれでブランコの1箇所が完成ですほ
じゃあ ok カンピー次に増える阿蘇
ok は4結んで漁師はい気持ち言われました
完璧ですちゃんと4カ所に紐がつきました続いてはこのマジック
大谷が4型 j な正方形同じ高さになるように設置していきます多分なが平べったい
は
超いって書いてあったのでドアのほうがいいかなドアにつけていきます
でこんなので本当に10キロも耐えられるのでながすぐ心配なレベルなんですけど頭の
てっぺんがいた場所に置いてきますあります
はぜも強いなあこれ多分あっ強いがこれ
まあこれなんかなんだ
なかなか強い結構いける人が浮上しておりますこれあるぞわーっ
強いはいはしさぁ続いてはブランコの品をフックに変えていきます
大丈夫ん
[音楽]
を
水きそうだっ
全然全然一途を磨いて両サイドをこうすればもう完全に優れたですねこれは違うぐらい
もですね
[音楽]
はいを貼っ方をできたできたというかできましたーーー
すごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
メッツバウンドすっ
ちょっといたの枝は長さが気になるところではあるんですけどもうかないいたを使う
ことによってたい愛犬の軽量化を図っております対する上でいかがでしょうか
10キロ10キロ10キロ10分9人ですね女の人一人こんなから持ち上げられるんだ
クッション性があるんで怖いんですけど万端そうなればトランポリンなども可能である
ではないかという気がしますついに
家の中ねブランコができる日がやってきましたん
怖いなぁ大丈夫からブランドと映画前クーチャーべっとり強いなんですけども
すぐ根拠にねスゴイスゴイねこれまあ請求ずタブは完全にブランドでして乗ってるなぁ
って2
わー
dha
me
car
あっはぁ
goo
あっはっは
いいんだイラレ